ein us forschungsteam hat hinweise
darauf gefunden dass es einmal eine zeit
gegeben haben könnte
in der der mond bewohnbar war die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vermuten sogar dass das leben für etwa
vier milliarden jahren von der erde auf
den mond gelangt sein könnte
wie genau kommt das forschungsteam auf
dieses wirklich spektakuläre ergebnis
und was bedeutet das für zukünftige
mondmissionen die antworten jetzt bei
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
der mond gilt als äusserst
lebensfeindlicher gesteinsbrocken denn
er hat kein flüssiges wasser keine
atmosphäre und weiß extreme temperaturen
auf leben wie wir es kennen galt
deswegen auf dem mond lange für komplett
ausgeschlossen
ein forschungsteam aus den usa ist
sicher jetzt aber sicher vor langer zeit
muss unser mond mal ideale bedingungen
für leben geboten haben demnach gibt es
sogar zwei verschiedene zeiträume in
denen der mond theoretisch bewohnt
gewesen sein könnte und zwar einmal vor
4,5 milliarden jahren also kurz nach
seiner entstehung und dann noch einmal
rund eine milliarde jahre später nämlich
vor etwa 3,5 milliarden jahren nach
angaben des beteiligten forscher wird
schulze makuch zitat ein beachtliches
zeitfenster in dem nicht nur flüssiges
wasser auf der oberfläche des mondes
existiert haben könnte sondern auch
leben natürlich mikroben oder bakterien
und keine grünen männchen so der
mitautor der studie weiter das fazit des
forschungsteams ist also ganz klar
der mond sei lange nicht so trocken wie
man immer dachte in seiner frühzeit habe
er wahrscheinlich sogar sehr viel wasser
aufgewiesen
möglicherweise sogar genug um einen
ozean zu wild einigen dienste
entsprechend tatsächlich dafür dass der
mond sogar heute noch eher feuchtes
forschungsteams vermuten dass
beispielsweise krater an den mondpolen
an die nie sonnenlicht gelangt bis zu
einige hundert millionen tonnen eis
enthalten könnten eventuell ist das nur
ein kleiner rest von einer gigantischen
wassermenge auf dem mond die über viele
milliarden jahre ins all verdampft ist
2009 hatte ja schon drei jahren 1 eine
indische sonne die signatur
wasserhaltige mineralien auf der
mondoberfläche aufgespürt doch woher
stammt dieses wasser dazu gibt es
mehrere mögliche antworten dazu dirk
schulze makuch wir gehen davon aus dass
der mond
als resultat einer gigantischen
kollision der erde mit einem anderen
himmelskörper vor 4,5 milliarden jahren
entstand flüchtige stoffe könnten den
mond dann erhalten geblieben sein
vielleicht haben aber auch asteroiden
wasser mit auf dem mond gebracht oder
aber es gäste aus geschmolzenem gestein
heraus das forschungsteam verweist zudem
auf dem vulkanismus der auf dem mond
weit verbreitet ist und wohl vor 3,5
milliarden jahren für die entstehung der
so genannten schwarzen mond mehrere
verantwortlich war
auch so könnte wasser auf die
mondoberfläche gelangt sein
die hätte zudem auch eine atmosphäre auf
dem mond geschaffen die man sich dreimal
so dicht vorstellen könnte wie dieses
maß diese hat sich wohl aber sicher
nicht besonders lange gehalten so eine
studie eines anderen forschungsteams aus
dem vergangenen jahr
demnach sei solch eine gashülle in
weniger als 100 millionen jahren
verschwunden
ein ausschlusskriterium für ein
mögliches leben auf dem mond ist das
dennoch nicht so dass us forschungsteam
in der aktuellen studie
dafür müsste die chemische evolution
zwar innerhalb weniger millionen jahre
aus anorganischen baustein erste zellen
geschaffen haben aber die seien nicht
undenkbar
doch die damaligen lebensformen könnten
auch anders auf dem mond gelangt sein
und zwar von der erde aus ein äußerst
spannendes szenario denn vor etwa vier
milliarden jahre wurde die erde von
zahlreichen asteroiden ja bombardiert so
könnten mikroben richtung mond
geschleudert worden sein
falls sie den einschlag und die reise
zum mond überlebt haben hätten sie dann
dort weiter existieren können so das
forschungsteam die fachwelt jedenfalls
diskutiert über die neue studie hält es
aber nicht für komplett ausgeschlossen
dass es einmal flüssiges wasser auf dem
mond gegeben hat doch selbst wenn dies
der fall war heißt das nicht dass sich
in einer solchen zeitspanne auch leben
entwickelt haben könnte zudem machen
eine atmosphäre und wasser noch keinen
lebensfreundlichen planeten aus das sagt
das forschungsteam auch selbst auch wenn
der mond vor langer zeit mal äußerst
wasserreich gewesen sein sollte sprechen
geologische betrachtung eher für einen
feuchten dunst der kurzzeitig um die
felsige einöde zu finden war
was wir dagegen sicher wissen derzeit
sind die bedingungen auf dem mond
äußerst lebensfeindlich dennoch besteht
die möglichkeit dass auch heute noch
flüssiges wasser existiert sicher
nachweisen ließe sich das aber nur durch
eine lande sondern für die raumfahrt
jedenfalls wäre solch eine entdeckung
sicherlich eine sensation denn aus dem
wasser könnte man sowohl sauerstoff als
auch wasserstoff gewinnen und letzterer
ließe sich als antriebsstoff für raketen
nutzen wenn er kein video dazu und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht
ihr die ein wenig unzuverlässige abo
boxee auf youtube und ihr verpasst kann
wie du denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr
von mir persönlich von jedem upload und
zwar noch vor allen anderen täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meine schwester cara
klicks und social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
blogger vergessen und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
wasser auf dem mond da gibt es noch mehr
infos zum thema also bis dann bleibt
dran